[Music]
it's very important for us in the west
to understand that
asia is where the action is and people
in retail will already know this
but the bulk of consumer purchase and
growth in retail is shifting towards
asia
to give you a sense for uh the scale
of china if you take every dollar that
was spent online in the united states
last year that came to roughly 500 to
600 billion
china alone last year was 1.3 trillion
dollars which means china is larger than
the us plus uk plus japan plus germany
plus spain
and all of these markets combined so we
should spend some time thinking about
what's going on in there
especially with respect to retail and to
marketing
the first thing to understand about
china is that it's a very large
population
and roughly 50 of that population
is on the cell phone and it's connected
to the internet so you are looking at
roughly 700
to 800 million users who are on the
phone
compared to about 300 million users in
the united states
and the phone is a very important
tracking device
and the phone is actually creating a
substantial
impact on the lives of of individuals
through e-commerce
the offline retail experience is quite
bad
quite poor in china offline stores have
poor quality
very little variety targetability was
very poor prices were very high
enter e-commerce alibaba jd tencent
these large companies for a user sitting
in a small town
in china who is typically
exposed to five retail stores with
potentially
say 50 different types of shirts you can
log into the phone and get access to 10
000 different shirts
available at much cheaper prices and
delivered to you within one day unlike
the united states where
we have now walled gardens in technology
where social
is within facebook and e-commerce is
within amazon and searches within google
these platforms have kind of merged in
china to produce two very large
ecosystems the alibaba ecosystem
and the tencent ecosystem and if you are
within one of these ecosystems
search social commerce logistics
payments etc are seamlessly blended
together
two interesting things about the social
media and retail intersection
in china are worth noting one is
that within wechat which is a large
social media platform
um there is now the ability of every
small retailer
to have a storefront that is seamlessly
connected
to the social enterprise or the social
network
and that storefront will allow you to
generate engagement with your users
and convert that engagement into a
selling opportunity
another aspect that is worth noting is
what is coming out of china referred to
as social commerce
and the most famous company that is
doing this is a company called pin duo
dual
there is a huge desire by companies in
order to get engagement
advertising and and messaging amongst
users
and the insight of this company is why
don't we
just pay users to generate
engagement with their friends and this
always existed in marketing this we call
it referral marketing
but the way they implemented it was an
interesting business model
you would get a reduction in the price
of any product that you want
as a function of the number of users
that you bring in or alternatively you
could get a very massive price reduction
if you posted
a promotion sent by that brand to your
social media feed
etc so they have been able to bring down
the prices of a large number of products
quite dramatically and making it
affordable to users in tier two cities
in china which is where the massive
opportunity
arises
if you look at the united states if you
take
all the dollars that spend on retail and
ask what proportion of that is in
e-commerce it's roughly 12
china it's about 16-17 percent one way
to think about it just eighty-three
percent of the market is still open
and it's a massive market so there's
lots of room for
lots of companies including the chinese
companies
it's not easy however because it's a
local market
and models that may work in the west
will not work in china without some
porting and some brands have done a
great job of this
such as apple or walmart but some brands
have failed too for example amazon
failed in in in china so uh
with the right kind of localization
strategy it is possible
to win in a very large market
now the risk is twofold china is a
country where government
regulation is a substantial source of
investor risk
and as regulation changes or the
government changes its stance
on protectionist laws or how they think
about
e-commerce or the propagation of content
that can have
a massive impact on the business so
one has to go in with their eyes wide
open a
second source of risk is uh competition
with incumbents
is not easy for example in e-commerce
uh you have two ecosystems which is
vertically integrated into content
into payments into logistics uh into
social media
and into an advertising business and
these
competitors are fearsome they understand
the local market well
and it's not that easy to uh to compete
the marketplace is large enough
to allow for many players and i think
the general view
of a lot of businesses that are working
in this area
is of collaboration rather than
competition
i think we should all think of it as a
massive market